les allemands respire dont les régions
les infections hebdomadaires sont
inférieurs à 50 cas pour 100000
habitants
certaines restrictions ont été levées
librairie fleuriste et auto écoles ont
déjà rouvert dans quelques régions les
salles de sport de l'état de hesse ont
aussi été autorisée à rouvrir après
plusieurs mois de fermeture
vous pouvez l'imaginer c'est une journée
incroyable pour nous une belle journée
nous sommes désormais autorisés à ouvrir
nos studios de fitness dans deux états
fédéraux en particulier ici en s
nous sommes tous ravis un sommes heureux
nous étions enfermés depuis si longtemps
autre avancée la vente de boîtes
d'autotest dans les supermarchés des
tests anti génie qui s'effectue par
prélèvement nasal à domicile sans
oublier la mise en place dans le pays
deux stations gratuite de tesco vide 19
et bien quand c'est gratuit vous le
faites naturellement plus souvent et
plus facilement mais si cela n'avait pas
été gratuit
si je n'avais aucun symptôme alors je ne
serais pas si sûr de me déplacer
bien sûr qu'on ça ne coûte rien je le
fais à six mois des élections fédérales
angela merkel a ainsi fini par céder un
mécontentement croissant dans l'opinion
publique mais aussi au sein de son
propre gouvernement
la chancelière pourrait finalement
réussir à éviter de ternir la fin de son
mandat